hey guys Ryan right here tonight's I'm
gonna watch a video called don't hug me
I'm scared I've never actually seen this
video it's a viral video a really
popular one for those people who don't
know what viral means never actually
seen don't hug me I'm scared and there's
also a don't hug me I'm scared part two
so I'm gonna watch both of them right
now
it doesn't honestly sound appealing to
me the title kind of freaks me out
I don't know why shut up Maryam let's
we'll watch this
the Ryan right-wing
[Music]
I did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on guys let's get creative
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that soul agreed to never be
creative again
that was [ __ ] weird that was trippy I
wish I was on shrooms while watching
them that would have made the experience
turn this down that was like watching
insidious with [ __ ] puppets that was
uh okay
watch part two you seen part two now
Murray hasn't seen part two she's seen
part one so she walked through my door
my neighbor in case you guys don't know
who she is so we're about to watch part
two that was a really [ __ ] weird
that's what yeah it seems like it would
be one in her favorite video that's
really uncomfortable for me no I just
saw a horror movie trailer and that was
10 times creepier than that horror movie
trick
I feel icky come on guys stop mucking
around we only have five minutes until
our shows on that's not enough time
there's always time for a song time is a
tool you can put on the wall or wear it
on your wrist the past is far behind us
the future doesn't exist what's the time
it's quarter to nine time to have a bar
what do you mean already paged run scrub
scrub till the waters brown time is a
ruler to measure the day it doesn't go
backwards only one way watch it go round
like a merry-go-round going so fast like
a merry-go-round
[Music]
we don't really want to go over the
place for marking around I begged my dad
[Music]
and then what happened after the older
days time went into a day the changing
seasons the smell of hey look at your
hair grows isn't it strange
now time bigs your appearance change
[Music]
[Music]
it's out of my hands I'm gonna be a punk
don't worry I'll be fine eventually
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] it's so much scary I thought my
channel was bad if children came across
this is like so [ __ ] up to do to
someone I'm an adult a grown human being
and I am like this is so disturbing she
creeps me out I know you love it like
listen II like crack up over here and
I'm like who the [ __ ] is going on right
I like that more than the other one the
other one was too scary for me I feel
like this one was trying harder to be
strange ya know I did enjoy it I really
did like the clock getting mad about
yeah yeah this one made me laugh a
little bit more it wasn't as creepy but
the other one was creepier but yeah I
was pretty awful hey want a shower down
I feel like I was assaulted or something
yeah I don't feel good well if you're
new to the channel subscribe so you can
watch more weird videos yeah yeah
subscribe subscribe hang out with me and
my neighbor that's where you're gonna be
no yes you're no longer the Meg of the
channel you are now the neighbor of the
chin will you shout out to me Marie I
will kamikaze I believe that one day
Ryan will at least baba donk a donk one
of these women perhaps cats or someone
but yeah I would like a shout-out
damn right kamikaze I'm gonna do a
[ __ ] kamikaze into a woman's butt JJ
if you know what I mean right yeah yeah
all right she gets it
I'm gonna die I'm gonna kill a woman but
I'm gonna crash a plane I mean the the
term kamikaze comes up a lot in like
American pop culture those dudes
yeah suicide mission bling in those
soldiers we're so abused and the guy
that like Ranma platoon or whatever was
like this really like kind of like cult
leader is sort of terrifying person a
great name yeah name the great name
really must be pretty badass you know
how to lift spirits when you know around
us 1v1 if Dan meets girls online does he
have Seibert sex yes shut up please
okay Hoss 1v1 why are you looking to
have cyber sex to Seibert you wanna have
sex with Dan cyber the best we want to
do and then I'm 30 to be down I mean I
don't I don't I can't speak for Dan but
I'm sure I haven't quite asked them I
think he has a girlfriend uh he might be
gay who knows we actually don't know
that you're not female we don't know
that you could be a woman I just assumed
that you were a man based off the use of
the English language that you chose talk
like that except for this one chick
trust me
Michelle Fernet no Michelle yeah I know
she doesn't talk like that frequently
brought up subscriber
Michelle's really cool she's really cool
I'd have sex with her I hope she knows
that if you're watching Michelle which I
know you are I hope you know that
it's a weird relationship with your
subscribers yeah I've never seen it I'm
just trying to have sex with as many of
them as possible
mm-hmm if I can do that then we are okay
guys I will continue to make this
zero zero zero working on it been a year
and a half now
still trekking away I have sex with
right thanks awesome 1v1 I wanted to
take time to promote my sexuality for
all the ladies out there and I decided
to use your shoutout to do it thank you
nate thurmond you wanted me to shine out
of the TMNT video sorry buddy i go an
order of shout out requests and now your
turn is here nate thurmond this is Uma
Thurman's sun rose mm-hmm what's it like
living in like your mom's shadow and
knowing that ethan hawke gave birth to
you but ethan hawke i mean he talked to
you convert to you you mean he gave a
sperm and you became something out of
that sperm wouldn't it be cool if that
would be way cooler than uma Thurman
giving birth I mean you got a respect to
ethan hawke after that I'm picturing uma
Thurman giving birth and it's totally
like a Quentin Tarantino style with like
blood gushing and stuff yeah and she's
wearing the jumpsuit the yellow jumpsuit
that's what your mom gave birth and
congratulations
mom's a [ __ ] nutcase